[موسيقى]
ثانكس
الكبيره مهمه احيانا قد تكون الاشياء
الصغيره مهمه ايضا اعتقد انما انجزناه
بجمع فنانين شباب وتجارب ابداعيه يبدو
كانه شيء نقي خرج من باطن الارض لم ياتي
ذلك الدعم من مؤسسات ولم نسال حكومات او
اشخاص
اردنا فعلا ان يكون جزءا من المجتمع الفني
لذا اعتمدنا على امكانيتنا الماديه اردنا
كشباب التواصل مع الفنانين الاخرين من
الاجيال التي سبقتنا لتطوير طاقتنا الفنيه
وكذلك مع من يتولون الشان الفني في مؤسسات
الحكومه
[موسيقى]
او دبليو
عائلتي للسكني هنا وكنت في سن سته اعوام
دخلت المدرسه هنا في الصف الاول وكانت لنا
علاقات طيبه مع الجيران ونلعب معنا ثم
توطت العلاقات مع مجتمع الفنانين وذلك
يكتسب واهميه خاصه لي في جمهوريه
التواصل معهم فقط بعد انهاء المدرسه وصرت
افكر في كيفيه التعبير عن فني انا الان
اعقف على تحسين اداء في الغناء والموسيقى
والعازف على البيانو واسلوبي هو الكباريه
الاستعراضيه وهو اسلوب يجمع بين العاطفي
والتجريديه ذلك هو اسلوب الغنائي في
التعبير عن نفسه
برنس